這裡是 AI 101，全網最幽默的 AI 新聞
OpenAI 的年化營收
從逼近700億美元變成接近500億美元，前後才9天
這不是 OpenAI 9天少賺200億
而是前後用了不同的尺
那這把尺量的是什麼？
年化營收
通常是拿近期的營收速度外推成一整年
也就是說
年化營收不是已經實現的全年營收
事情要回到9月29日
新聞網站 Axios 報導
OpenAI 年化營收逼近700億美元
可是到了10月8日
《金融時報》看到 OpenAI 投資人文件
9月底只接近500億
那多出來的200億是誰灌的？
Axios 隨後澄清：
700億是投資人照 Anthropic
的口徑放大換算的
這200億差額不代表客戶或現金真的消失
Anthropic 的算法又差在哪？
假設一張100美元的帳單
客戶透過雲端平台買 AI 服務
Anthropic 可能整張都算營收
OpenAI 對某些通路，只算自己留下的
兩種算法哪個才對？
差別在公司被判定是控制服務的主理人
還是協助銷售的代理人
兩種都可能符合美國一般公認會計原則
也就是 GAAP
帶著兩把尺回頭看營收賽跑
2025年底
OpenAI 大約是 Anthropic 的2.4倍
Anthropic 一路追趕，4月6日首度越線
7月底更傳出超過650億
但問題是，這場賽跑的刻度可能不一樣
Axios 早在8月就提醒
兩家公司量營收的尺可能不同
只是這句註腳當時沒什麼人注意
那500億代表 OpenAI 需求崩盤嗎？
並沒有
知情人士提供的資料顯示
OpenAI 仍在高速成長：
第三季年化營收速度成長77%
企業業務更增加107%
儘管如此，消息一曝光
AI 基礎建設股跌勢加快
提供 AI 雲端運算的 CoreWeave
當天跌約8%
Oracle、Nvidia 也下跌
不過同一天，油價上漲、債市也劇烈反轉
市場這麼敏感
是因為 OpenAI 正洽談新資金
投前估值約1.4兆美元
拿500億年化營收粗算
等於28倍的營收速度
投資人押的是未來的成長
付不付得起算力帳單
而年化這把尺，很容易放大高速成長
Anthropic 2025年全年營收約46億美元
2026年7月年化卻已超過650億
這不是造假，比較像拿最後1公里的速度
推算整場馬拉松
所以回到 OpenAI：
公司仍預期年底達到或超過700億
但完整的通路對帳資料沒有公開
市場卻拿這個沒有統一算法、
也不是已實現全年營收的指標
去衡量兆美元估值
下次再看到年化700億
先問用的是哪一把尺